Speaker 1: Donald Trump came out hot from his
deposition yesterday with New York Attorney
General Letitia James. Trump pleaded the fifth
more than 400 times, despite previously claiming
only the mob and guilty people plead the Fifth.
And then he spent the day absolutely losing it
on his platform. Truth Social. Take a look at
what the president spent the afternoon doing.
First of all, posting all sorts of different
videos, attacking Letitia James and attack videos
of different kinds, then saying at the very plush,
beautiful and expensive attorney general's office,
nice working conditions as people are being
murdered all over New York and she spends her time
and effort on trying to get Trump. Trump then
continuing and posting this entire statement about
how Letitia James campaigned on getting Trump.
And she's a racist and she's hostile and she's
just determined to go after him. A multi-page
tirade that makes absolutely no sense if you've
been following the facts of the investigation.
Trump then continuing about the raid, saying he
participated and it was a surprise attack and
it was all without warning or notification.
Trump then saying, just leaving the attorney
general's office a very professional meeting,
having a fantastic company with great assets,
very little debt and lots of cash only in America
even that doesn't appear to be true at this
point about Donald Trump's businesses. Trump
then posting a picture of a police car outside
Mar a Lago with an article from the New York Post
posting that, in fact, multiple times, just
spending his entire day posting all of this stuff.
And he wants all of us to believe things that are
simply unbelievable and not true. Trump wants us
to believe that because he was participating
in conversations with the FBI that the search
warrant must have been illegal or immoral. In
fact, legal experts have pointed out, Oh, no,
no, no. The fact that Trump was in contact with
the FBI and they still issued a search warrant
suggests that Trump was not actually providing to
the FBI when he was supposed to provide. It's not
better. It doesn't look better for Trump that the
warrant was served after he was speaking them. It
actually looks worse. Donald Trump wants us to
believe that him even being deposed by Letitia
James is some horrible act of unfairness and
injustice and whatever else the case may be.
This is a guy who has spent five years using
every legal mechanism he could think of to avoid
releasing his taxes to anyone, including the
House, including anybody. Despite claiming as
soon as his audits were over, he would release
them. Who has spent the time avoiding having to
be deposed in sexual assault allegation cases?
Multiple of them, which I have told you about,
trying to avoid providing all sorts of records
to all sorts of different agencies who has tried
to avoid being deposed by Letitia James on every
single one of these. Donald Trump has gone above
and beyond what any normal person would be allowed
to get away with or could afford to get away with.
And so with all the people who have now come
out of the woodwork from the right saying,
you know, we've got to be really worried. Trump's
deposition, the search warrant at Mar a Lago
If it could happen to Trump, it could happen
to any of us. It happens to all of us all the
time. We're. The two tiered justice system is very
clear, and we deal with this stuff all the time.
It's the Trumps of the world that often don't have
to deal with it. And it's absolutely stunning that
now they are pulling all of this. So Donald Trump
clearly with much free time to just post and post
and post to truth social. And the next question
becomes, what is the next step? And I know that,
you know, think about Matt Gaetz. We learned about
the Matt Gaetz child sex trafficking investigation
in March of 2021. Nothing has really happened
yet. These things can take a long time. And I
know that there are many of you anxious to see.
Well, what's the next thing? What's Letitia James
going to do? What's the DOJ going to do after the
search warrant at Mar a Lago? Will it happen this
week? Next week? The next week after that? Maybe.
But this stuff can take months, if not years.
So my suggestion is let's take it a day at a
time. Right now, the focus really should be
the 2022 midterms. We can't do anything about
the timing of these investigations into Trump.
We actually can do something in November
which is voting, and that means down ballot,
and that means in every race available for
you to vote in. That should be the focus.
We will take a quick break. If you want
to look at some of these clips and posts,
find them on our Instagram at David Pakman
show. We're going to be back very, very soon.